what do you think is the distaste that
parents have with trades I think
everything comes down to status I would
imagine that most parents want to be
able to say that they did a good job of
being parents and so they use their
children as a proxy for how good of
people they are and so if they can go
and say hey my kid is doing X Y and Z it
is perceived as high Prestige versus my
kid is an electrician even though he
makes more than being a social media
manager at insert random mid-market
company they would get more Prestige
from social media because it's white
collar versus blue color from a dollars
and sense standpoint from a return on
investment staple and arguably from an
enjoyment of Life standpoint that person
who might be inclined to be an
electrician or a plumber or whatever
might actually like that more and have a
better life but I think it's selfishness
at its core